aneta Louie has lived in Istanbul for
four years her children go to a German
school but today it was closed because
of the terror alert mine anti zone is EF
at once my older son feels unsafe even
with all the police presence my younger
son is a bit more at ease but since
school was closed today there's a whole
other dimension to this situation
because the warning was so concrete my
desaturation acafellas ahead dad even on
yet so concrete sins there's also a
stronger police presence at the german
consulate in Istanbul all German
cultural and diplomatic offices remained
closed today the origin of the terror
alert is unclear authorities did not
want to comment on the nature of the
threat or the nationalities of possible
attackers neighboring shopkeepers
learned of the alert through media
reports police told us they had the
situation under control and there was no
cause for concern that's why we didn't
closed for business today and visitors
had a range of reactions to the growing
threat of terrorism in Turkey it's the
terrorists who should be afraid not us
they should fear the police on the whole
nation we came for a soccer match
between two Turkish teams and now we're
a bit scared my colleagues want to go to
the stadium by train but I'd rather take
a taxi because I'm afraid something
might happen a net to Louis loves living
on the Bosphorus she hopes Istanbul will
be calm again and that her children's
school will reopen soon